[Applause]
all right talking about people that
should kill themselves do you think
kylie jenner should kill her
for her donation to her friends go fund
me
uh this is a tricky thing with being
rich you can't help nobody publicly if
you don't do the whole thing
i'm saying bro you know that's her
mistake is posting to try to get like if
she just gave the money on the low and
let them talk about it yeah
oh that's nice kylie jenner paid all
this money blah blah blah but the second
she
was like hey i gave you know 50 cents
for me or whatever can you all give
a significant more amount of money but
it's also not fully fair
because apparently their goal is like
through gofundmes if it's like a friend
of mine to see how cheap
people i know
like i remember there was one for the
second if you see a dollar from
anonymous that's your boy
i remember it was one for the seller
somebody had i forget who needed some
[ __ ] the seller maybe somebody died and
i was looking through
and i was looking to see how much i was
like let me see how cheap these rich
[ __ ]
are you judging the rich ones though
right and i'm looking through and i
think amy schumer i got to amy schumer
and i was like born into hate and she
dropped like 20 grand on it and i was
like
all right [ __ ] hey you good you good
today
you're good today you joke stealing ass
[ __ ]
you might as well put that money to good
use
she donated to the guy she stole jokes
from she's like there you go you can
have my back
oh my god yeah uh but yeah man she so
the story
is that akash can you break down so from
what i understand
uh she had a makeup artist that she
stopped working with in like 2015
he got in a car accident but he's still
close friends with her current makeup
artist
so she was trying to help them out and
she just posted about it and the initial
goal i i think was like ten thousand
dollars gotcha and she gave
five and that put them over the top of
their goal so she got them to
the goal but then everybody kept coming
to the page and so the family
which i can't really it's funny but i
can't really blame him i was like we
might as well raise the [ __ ] goals
people are coming wow so they raised it
to 60 000 and now she looks cheap as
[ __ ] with her 5 000
donation oh so they [ __ ] her over i
think that's yeah
i mean tmz i think was the article i
read but i could also see them wanting
to
maintain a good relationship again
because it's at 120.
is it really right now there you go so
yeah that'd be right right now all right
see that's
that's interesting yeah that's now
there's more context because everybody
was absolutely [ __ ] all over kylie
on internet because like oh you only
gave 5 000 when you know their goal is
000 or whatever but also didn't kylie
like pump it she was like yo if you guys
can donate donate to this yeah she did
pump it but she also
met the goal right so she's like she's
going oh this is all you need
i got it i'm going to pay for your
medical bills they're saying
they're basically like my medical bills
are 10 grand right so she's like
ah there you go it's paid for and now
people are criticizing her on the
internet
for not paying the amount that they need
after they manipulated the amount that
they need
so they can get more money in it but the
fact that she
post the gofundme on the before we talk
about this anymore your family didn't
move the amount for the gofundme did
they
okay just making sure
the fact that she said hey people go to
the gofundme that means
the the money wasn't met yet the amount
wasn't met yet
no just because the money's met doesn't
mean that you can't continue to get more
but the family probably went well if
it's met then [ __ ] ain't going
to donate
but if it looks like we need some more
money that's why every good deed goes
what is it no
unpunished man ain't that [ __ ] up she
did the right thing
here i am about to trash this [ __ ] when
she did the right thing you need to get
to a certain amount i
got you because that's what it costs to
fix your [ __ ] leg or whatever it is
yeah and all of a sudden when
[ __ ] start donating
your leg needs more fixing yeah what the
[ __ ]
yeah i gotta pay your bills no that's
[ __ ] up
that is [ __ ] up i still think it's
[ __ ] up because if he was the makeup
artist that took her from
ugly to how she looked when she was 18.
that was surgeons dog with no makeup and
also
2015. that's 2015.
she got rid of that [ __ ] when
she glowed up
now how old is she right now that's i
think 23 years old in 19 days
[Laughter]
exactly so how old is she i don't know i
don't know
uh let me check she's 23 is you're a
creep
[Laughter]
as of june 3rd no but that's
what's crazy is that means if she if she
was working with him back then
she was under 18. yeah maybe tiger
didn't like her you know what i mean
nothing that's all it was she had a big
blow up when she was working
raping me doesn't like you so i have to
move on yeah i don't know she had the
biggest club what she was doing
what are you putting that on tiger yeah
yeah come on sir they weren't having sex
or nothing yeah
yeah i mean come on bro why would you
even say that it's tiger right
he's chilling bro he's just [ __ ] down
you're right i'm sorry tiger yeah you
think that big old dangle angle fitting
an underage girl now
come on dude i'm sorry dog i'm sorry bro
i took a shot unnecessarily first of all
for a cheap laugh
cheap laughs yeah you know who else is
cheap
no i know i feel bad for kylie man
what i'm doing bro she the victim i see
it both ways where it's like
if she were to
[Laughter]
that's like like one fraction like tiny
fraction of her net worth so she could
just meet it and be like whatever
assuming that they didn't move the goal
post on the whole deal yeah
but at the same time i also don't like
when people criticize rich people for
not donating enough
because it's like you can donate that
percentage of your net worth you know
what i mean when people like oh
jeff bezos can donate all this money to
stop the hunger in america
like you could donate five percent of
your net worth
to feed a homeless guy but you don't do
that that's a good argument that's a
good argument bugs when people criticize
you you're just offloading your guilt
yeah exactly like when people criticize
rich people for not doing enough it's
like you can do five percent of what you
have
yeah but you don't do that but you are
expecting this guy to do five percent of
what he has
some people might make the argument that
like he has more money than there are
things to buy
right yeah so like that percentage is a
little bit different but
whatever that's fair but it doesn't
exonerate you from having it done
exactly yeah 100 i just feel like if
they move the goal post
she's getting all this [ __ ] and they
they owe her an apology like because
she's the only reason that they're
getting a hundred something thousand
dollars in right 100
it's poor girl that's why if you're rich
you can't [ __ ] help people man
you gotta do it quietly you really gotta
do it and you got to be careful who you
help
like like our boy abdi was trying to get
me to like donate money to get this
somali dude from somalia
into turkey to get a [ __ ] like uh
liver transplant or some [ __ ] and i'm
just like
do you know who they are and then it's
like my mom saw him on tick tock and i'm
like
buddy i can't donate thousands of
dollars
to a random somali group and then it
comes out later
it's a [ __ ] terror organization they
use that [ __ ] to blow up a [ __ ]
grocery store and now i'm the person
that funded blown up the grocery store
right i need more than just a tick tock
video to verify that this thing is legit
what if it's just pirates
yeah yeah exactly i'd actually like yeah
owning like a pirate you want to give
the pirates a booty yeah
yeah i don't know why they don't do that
for those like commercials where they
show all the kids
or like like where you can like donate
money you have a little [ __ ] pirate
standard
yeah don't leave me a letter
[Laughter]
i like the idea that like they're
criminals like they're doing you know
[ __ ] up [ __ ] on the seas but it don't
seem that bad like do people die
with the pirate ship [ __ ] yeah i don't
think they
don't know any we don't know anybody
that's on sea like that nobody cares
yo if you get your whole boat robbed
you're a [ __ ] yeah somebody pulls up a
little skiff
you've got some somalis on the back of
it kicking their legs man hard to get it
to catch up to your ass and then they
steal
all the containers on your boat i can't
wait till he buys a boat i know
because you know that time is coming let
me tell you something and you're gonna
buy a boat
hey both of the [ __ ] boats hold on
shout out we got a shout out to the
company that took us out man shout out
to boy robert brother hey
robert taylor shout out robert yo shout
out robert taylor robert taylor is out
of town
rentals downtown underscore exotic
underscore rentals
they have some amazing boats if you're
in miami you want to take a boat out
this is a a plug that we do a hundred
percent
supportive of this guy was absolutely
amazing took us all out for alex's b day
we had an incredible time
amazing boat thank you and uh yo thank
you so much robert the fan of the
parties
[ __ ] army provides i'm telling you we
always try to keep the [ __ ] over here
so if you are coming to miami or going
to
any other city shout out to the [ __ ]
see if they got anybody in the city that
can help you out with what you need to
do
telling you robert got it locked down
we're on that [ __ ] boat yeah and
i don't know how expensive maintaining
boats are and all that kind of [ __ ]
but there is something about being on a
boat and i
don't understand why but every second of
it
feels purposeful you're not doing
nothing different than what we're doing
right now but you're going somewhere
you're going somewhere you don't know
where you're going you're going
somewhere you're going in circles
and then you put the anchor down and
it's still fun
yeah you're taking a break from going
somewhere mark you're not saying
anything
yeah but you're right but you're not
saying it's like we're on a boat
why the [ __ ] is the boat so entertaining
yeah i don't know
please explain this to me i felt relaxed
the one time i was on a boat
but that's it oh you weren't with us
again
oh you left us again you wouldn't hang
out with us again yeah should be seen in
too high
like high intensity you weren't going a
boat
hold on you wouldn't go on a boat bro
what do you mean you wouldn't go on a
boat what are we doing on this boat
oh my gosh bro we played dominoes we
played uno for like a hour
i'll take back my invitation for
national work
no no it's because it's not the top of a
train that's why
yo you would go that's purposeful there
we go why are you going something now
that's where you go that's exciting you
can only go one hour
in the sand